The Path, the war path,
path of war,
moving toward a battle,
fight towards
the actual war against our nation's enemies. Yes.
The war against my own weaknesses.
Preparing
and sharpening my sword and homie my skills and maintaining [inaudible] on
mitigated daily discipline. Flint
in all things.
Where does it lead?
Uh,
you can blog too. It's fun fact,
uh,
ready
because the warpath is a,
it's so, it leads to strength.
It's a war against ignorance,
leads to knowledge.
[inaudible] movers
don't war path to
ownership.
And that is the war path.
The path
versus the path of blood. And the sweat in of suffering
is the preeminent path of distance, which is why
and beyond that,
oh.